I don't let the stupid and dorky measure me
by the Lord that was not a personal fact
that was I want marked
that is possible but that was not a personal fact
you must also admit chairman thank you sir
Mr Baudet
which indicates on behalf of the forum for democracy
that you shouldn't be binary yourself
pronounce for 1 party
when it comes to
the Palestinians and Israel
I would like to ask the Lord baudet
whether that is not correct what forum for democracy does
Mr.
Baudet and we have several
pictures of seen
in which he wears 1 T-shirt of the Israelites
fansforce
and in voting behavior
I'm talking about really 1 few months ago
has form for democracy
against taking measures
against the annexation of
Palestinian territory
the voted against 1 few months ago
voted against 1 motion to
the israeli government
to appeal to
polarizing statements by the secretary of defense
against the raising of illegal annexations
against punishment
of the person responsible for war crimes
in the direction of the Palestinians
forum for democracy
has shown to this day
that they chose binary
for the Israeli government
for the interests of the Government of Israel
so in voting behavior
and also in the expressions
which the Lord has shown baudet
is it in light of that
his argument is totally unbelievable
the Lord baudet lifts that
no and i like it too
typical that
probably the only party in this room that
is willing to say to you
I say to you
that I understand your argument
and like that I share many points
and that's that outstretched hand right away with that one
party politics
with I FOUND SOMETHING
I'm going to hit you around the ears
for 1 looks for democracy
as objective as possible
as substantively as possible to subjects
and if we sometimes do it with
think we have common ground we sometimes agree
sometimes we disagree
and we are very constructive about that
so I find it 1 bit bland
and I find it really disappointing
that mister van bearded do not think of that created
contradictions in our society
who can step into created contradictions
and can work with us
ok what is the way
immediately roll back with things from the past
but then that happened and it is not
this is what i just told is our integrity
vision of what is going on in the world now
this is what we think
and I would say
try to find the common ground
I think there are quite a few
lord of Baarlo
chairman but I also question Mr.
Baudet
on credibility and integrity
of his vision
exactly my point chairman
and that is not bland
that is 1 point that think is very important
namely standing up for the rights of Palestinians
and I note
that forum for democracy and think differences
I note that forum for democracy
until 1 few months ago
the last time it was voted on
all motions to the Israeli government
to be held accountable for 1 illegal annexation policy
voted against it
that the Lord always baudet in all forms in this
in this matter
has shown
that the Lord baudet personally
by wearing
of 1 T-shirt of the israel defence force
to be on the side of Israel
of the Israeli government
then here is now 1 pleading
we shouldn't choose
is totally unbelievable and not honest
because that has a forum for democracy
to this day
always done
so dumb this so disappointing
so dorky but I want to go into it
look at all those motions that the Lord calls of value
those are not motions
they are about what do we think of 1 situation
but those are
universalist
neo conservative
interventionistische motions and that there
we do not support
because we are for real politics
so we do not support the Dutch government either
solve inflation in Argentina
or that the Dutch government
armed hand must defend the oeigurs in China
or we
believe that the Netherlands should be cautious
international
and must think of the Dutch interest as we do
people
from other countries to drag before tribunals
here what was 1 motion example
we are not there
we are against the international criminal court at all
we are against it
so we are not going to advocate that leaders of
Hamas before the International Criminal Court in The Hague
must be tried because we are against
that kind of international
courts
that has
that has nothing to do with us
take sides with Israel
so now exactly that diegotomy that that
oh if you are not 100
for the 1 with then you are for the other
you sit you are in exactly
you let yourself be in exactly the same
draw conflict
that your practice is for that
that you have to side with that
we voted against those motions
because we are not for it
interventionistische politics from the Netherlands
the whole standing up for the Dutch interest
otherwise I have indeed
in the past and had a different point of view
about the situation in Israel I Am
in it
yes I have developed in that
I have learned to see that more broadly
and the time that I
1 Israel defence forces T-shirt
was the year 2008 when I was there 1
had a great journey and was very impressed by it
what I saw
I am still very impressed by the way
of what the Jews have done in Israel
that is natural
incredibly special
it is 1 very special people
they have done very special things
but a lot of crimes have also been committed
in the West Bank and Gaza
where I gradually more
got an eye for HAVE
and vice versa there are also
committed a lot of crimes
from Palestinians to Jews
and
it's terrible
it's terrible that that's still going on
we now threaten in 1
violence escalation
who it
makes terrible for many more people
and I don't want to
face you
mister van bearded
I don't want to face other people either
i think that
wisdom and prudence now one of the rarest
rare virtues are
but that we have to call for that and
I hear that sound far too little
thank you no sorry
personally I have not heard
yes I chair
I think we had 1 nice substantive debate